大家好，我叫戴维·布朗，这是一堂发音课。你好，戴维老师。我
很好，谢谢。您怎么样？我非常好。谢谢。谢谢。欢迎。
谢谢您，戴维老师。您准备好上今天的课了吗？是的。好的。好的。那么我们
可以练习一下我看到您选择的这节课的内容。我们有这个短
i 音和这个长 e 音。短 i 音听起来像 /ɪ/，然后
长 e 音听起来像 /iː/，对吗？好的。这对我们来说掌握起来很重要，因为它
可能会给英语母语者造成困惑，而且这确实是
一对经常被读错的音。我们这里有一些例子。一些有趣的
例子。我们有 fill 和 feel，sit 和 seat，chip 和
cheap。这个是 bit。这个是 beat, beat, ship，而这个是 sheep。这个
是 lid，而这个是 lead。好的。所以我们需要知道 /ɪ/ 音和
/iː/ 音之间的区别，/ɪ/ 音和 /iː/ 音。好的。
短 /ɪ/ 音与长 /iː/ 音的区别。这就是我们今天课上要练习的内容。两个
不同的音。例如，这是什么？这是 ship*, ship，非常好。而这个，
这些是 sheep。这些是 sheep，对吧？规则复数名词。所以我们
正在学习两个可能有点棘手但对于清晰发音非常非常重要的
英语发音。我们希望理解并被理解，而这会
影响我们的理解能力。所以它可以改变词语的意思。我们有这个词
ship，还有这个词 cheap，这只是一个例子。所以今天我们
这里有两个目标。我希望你们听一下这些目标。今天你们
将学会听辨 /ɪ/ 和 /iː/ 之间的区别，并更清晰地发出 /ɪ/ 和 /iː/ 的音。让我们
试试这个。你能跟我重复一遍吗？/ɪ/。现在，/iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/。太棒了。所以我们这里有一个小小的
练习活动。我说过你们需要像一根棍子和一块积木
这样的东西。所以我有一支彩色铅笔和我女儿的一块积木。你有什么
东西吗？好的，是的，是的，我有一些东西。好的，好的，像这样。好吧，那么让我们
想象我们发出 /ɪ/ 音，就像敲击一块积木一样。好的，对吧？所以敲击 /ɪ/
你的积木，说 /ɪ/。现在我们有 /iː/ 音，它更长。你可以想象你拿着
你的铅笔在某个东西上拖动，/iː/, /iː/, /iː/。很好，/iː/。好吧，那么
再听一遍，/ɪ/, /ɪ/ /iː/, /iː/。注意你的下巴会变化。你的舌头在口腔中的位置，
发一个音时比另一个音时更高。这完全取决于你舌头在口腔中的位置，
/iː/ 音对比 /ɪ/ 音，/ɪ/ 音更放松一些。好的。你听出
区别了吗？是的。好的，非常好。所以短 i 音，即 /ɪ/ 音，与 /iː/ 音
有点不同，/iː/ 音更……，而且是舌头位置更高的 /iː/ 音。我们发
/ɪ/ 音时下巴更低一些，/iː/，看我的嘴型，/iː/，对吧？好的，现在你
不想发 /ɛ/ 音，这是，我们有像 lead (金属 - jīnshǔ) 这样的 /ɛ/ 音，我们有像 lid 这样的 /ɪ/ 音，
然后我们有像 lead (引导 - yǐndǎo) 这样的 /iː/ 音。所有这些都取决于你舌头在口腔中的位置。
我们有 /ɛ/, /ɪ/, 和 /iː/。跟我重复，/ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/   /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/
/iː/。非常好。好的，所以根据你舌头或下巴的位置，这些音会有一些差异。
所以你的嘴需要比发西班牙语的 /i/ 音时张得更开一点。
你的嘴唇是放松的，不是微笑状，也不是紧绷的。所以对于 /ɪ/ 音，它更像是
这样一点点，它只是 /ɪ/, /ɪ/, 对吧？不是 /ɛ/。舌头位置略高，略微
靠前，你需要稍微放松你的舌头。它是一个快速、短促的
音，就像轻轻敲击积木的声音，对吧？好的。感受它，放松。那么试着
自己发出这个音。你可以静音。再试着自己发出这个音。让
我听听。好的，/ɪ/, /iː/ 然后是 /ɪ/, 和 /iː/, 非常好。太棒了。好的。好吧。
仅仅这一点点练习就能产生很大的不同。那么现在我希望你
给我看看……你可以用镜子，也可以用摄像头。如果你太害羞不愿用摄像头，
用镜子也可以。那么看着摄像头里你的嘴。
好的。像这样。你可以看到 /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, 不是 /ɛ/, 而是 /ɪ/... /ɪ/ , 还有 /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, 完美。
好的，所以你的嘴，嘴唇张得很宽，像拉开的橡皮筋一样，用于发
/iː/ 音，舌位高而靠前，你能感觉到一点点紧张。所以
我们有，这个，也就是 /iː/ 音，这是 /ɪt/，而这个是 /iːt/，对吧？对。
它是一个长的、拉伸的音，像拉东西一样。所以你可以想象发 /iː/ 音时，
就像有橡皮筋拉着你的嘴角一样。
所以你可以在这里的图片中看到这个。这里有 /ɪ/ 音，它在中间
靠前的位置。下巴半合拢，是放松的。然后 /iː/ 音时嘴唇咧得更开。
嘴巴闭合度更高一些，舌头也更靠上一些。
做得很好。好的，那么我们来练习一些。这里有一个活动。你已经拿到了
你的积木和铅笔或钢笔，或者随便什么，或者棍子。好的。那么当你，当我读，
或者当，当你读到一个包含这个短 /ɪ/ 音的词时，我希望你敲一下积木。
好的。然后当它包含长 /iː/ 音时，我希望你滑动你的棍子。准备好了吗？
我准备好了。好的。那么 ship。重复，ship, ship。
嗯哼。Ship. Ship. Get. Bed. Bed. Beats. Beats. Ship. Ship. 还有 ship.
Sheep. 很好。Sit. 很好。Fill. Feel. Feel. 很好。好的。我们可以用这个 /ɪ/ 音再多练习一下。
/ɪ/ 音。